i i see all our speakers here
so it's my pleasure to begin our session
today with the talk by
sierra pikeberg and she is
she's going to present a work for third
and sierra it has been my pleasure to
co-author a paper with sierra
and uh and it's very exciting to see all
the recent work that she's been doing on
on episodic reinforcement learning and
i'm really looking forward to hearing
about this new paper
thanks uh yeah i'm kira pikeberg
and i'm going to be speaking about our
paper a unifying view of optimism and
exotic reinforcement learning which is
joint work with gurgaon
so we consider the episodic rl problem
so here we
start off with some initial state x1 we
take an action
we transition to a new state x2 and we
also receive some reward as a result of
doing that
from at state x2 we then take another
action and transition to another state
and receive another reward and we keep
doing that
up to eight times so a bit more formally
we have two episodes and each one
consists of eight stages
in each stage of each episode we observe
the state we select an action
we receive some reward and then we
transition to a new state
importantly in this work we're going to
assume that the transition function is
unknown
but the reward is known and that's what
we will call the episodic reinforcement
learning problem
oh i meant to say if i talk really fast
please just wave at me and i can slow
down
so in each episode t we want to select a
policy pi
and a policy is going to be a sequence
of actions so that says
from this state we're going to take this
particular action
and in particular we want to select a
policy that has high value
so here we define the value as the
total reward from some initial state
acting according to our policy
when the transition function is given by
this
p here and
using this we can define an optimal
policy which is the one that maximizes
the value
so if we have a mdp where we know the
transition
there are a couple of ways that we can
go about finding this optimal policy
so the first one we're going to think of
is using occupancy measures
so we define occupancy measure q as
as the probability that we're in state x
and we take action a
and so for every occupancy measure it
will define a policy
pi and we can just use this ratio here
to define that
so using this notion to find an optimal
policy pi
we can find an optimal occupancy measure
and this
octamor occupancy measure can be found
by solving this lp here
so this i don't know if you can see my
mouse but this
this term here is just the value so it's
the
amount of time we spend in state x
taking action a and the reward from
doing so
summing over all states and actions then
the constraints in this queue x1 will
just guarantee that
our occupancy measures are valid so
they're positive and that they start
from some initial state x1 and this
constraint here is what we call the flow
constraint so this
just makes sure that the amount of mass
going into state x is the same as the
amount of mass leaving state x
and it's well known that the jewel of
slp
is has a very nice form in particular
we can interpret these optimal variables
here these these as the value functions
and then we can solve this by a
backwards recursion starting from big h
and what's nice is that they exhibit
strong duality because they're linear
programs and the optimal solutions to
both
is going to be the optimal value
function from an initial state x1
so then if we don't know p what we want
to do is we want to try and minimize our
regret
so we select a sequence of policies pi t
and we want to minimize the difference
between the value of that policy
compared to the value of the optimal
policy
in this setting we have a lower bound
for regret which is h
square sat
and common to a lot of problems where we
consider regret minimization
a common technique is to apply the
optimistic principle
and the optimistic principle basically
says we want to act optimally in the
best statistically plausible world
so to sort of put that into context
we're going to consider a really simple
problem with a bandit problem
where we basically have one state and h
is also equal to one
so we just have a sequence of actions
each one has some
unknown mean and what we do is we
construct confidence bounds around
our empirical s of the mean and each
within these confidence bounds these are
what we call the feasible worlds
world we're going to be looking at the
highest upper confidence bound here
and so this leads to the well-known ucb
algorithm
that just plays the highest upper
confidence band of each arm
however in rl there are two ways that we
can use optimism
so the first is what we'll call the
model optimistic framework
so here we have our empirical density
measure which is estimated from data
and we're going to construct a
confidence set around it such that the
true transition
function will be in that confidence set
with high probability
we then jointly optimize over this
confidence set and the policy space to
find an optimal policy
an optimistic policy even and some
examples of algorithms that do this
include ucrl and klecrl
alternatively we can consider value
optimistic algorithms
so here we directly build on the ucb
framework to add a confidence down to a
value function
this means that we can compute an
optimal policy via dynamic programming
by just using the empirical transition
function and adding some uncertainty
bonus here
and examples of this algorithm include
ucbvi and uc
ubev so
model optimistic algorithms because they
construct this set of transition
functions
it's quite easy to show that the true
transition function is in it so this
facilitates a simple probabilistic
analysis
however value optimistic algorithms in
this case showing optimism can be a bit
more complex but yeah we often have to
use some complex recursive arguments
so we're going to say the probabilistic
analysis is a little bit more complex
however when it comes to the
implementation this joint optimization
problem here
is pretty tricky so it's quite a
computationally
inefficient to implement model
optimistic algorithms
whereas on the other hand value
optimistic algorithms can be implemented
simply by
dynamic programming so this is very easy
to implement
when it comes to the existing algorithms
the best known regret we have for model
optimistic algorithms are loose by a
factor of score s
whereas value optimistic algorithms are
known to match lower bound up to
logarithmic factors
so on paper these two methods of these
two classes of methods the value
optimistic and model optimistic
algorithms seem quite distinct
however what we're going to show in this
work is that there is in fact quite a
deep connection between them
and in particular we show this by
demonstrating that the two optimization
problems solved by the two classes of
algorithms
exhibit strong duality
so our main result is to show that every
model optimistic algorithm
has an equivalent representation as a
value optimistic algorithm
so this basically means we can define
confidence sets using the empirical
transition function and then implement
it by dynamic programming
so i'm going to quickly go through the
key ideas of proof of this result
we first take start writing the model
optimistic
optimization problem using these
occupancy measures so this is very
similar to the initial
um lp we saw for when the transition
function was known
but we replaced the known transition
function with this variable p
tilde and then constrain p tilde to sit
in our confidence set
this optimization problem is
unfortunately
bilinear so we have this variable p
multiplying this variable q
and that means it's not super easy to
show any duality or to do anything
particularly particularly normal
instead we can reparameterize the
problem so if we introduce these
variables j
we see that our first flow constraint
becomes linear
and due to the assumption we make about
our distance metric we can write our
write the confidence set in a nice form
as well so i should have mentioned that
we assume that our distance measure d
here
that defines these confidence sets is
convex in both arguments
and positive homogeneous which means
that we can multiply it by a constant
and just take the constant out
so once we have this re-parameterized
form it's a lot nicer and we can
go to the next step which is writing
lagrangian down this looks a bit scary
but basically what we do is we write the
lagrangian without the constraint that
appears in the confidence set
then using the fact that these queues
are positive variables
we can pull that constraint inside
and then we see that this term here is
essentially just going to be
what we'll call the conjugate so this is
this d star function defined here
and from that we can just write down the
joule from the lagrangian and we call
this
conjugate distance here we're going to
use this as our confidence term
which is some measure of the uncertainty
that we have
about v in this particular instance
and so what this result has shown is
that we can start from model optimistic
framework
and we can end up with a value
optimistic implementation
so there are a couple of other things we
need to show before we're done
so we can show the optimal model
optimistic policy
satisfies value optimistic bellman
equations so that basically
tells us that the policies we get from
these two optimization problems
are almost equivalent in fact they are
equivalent if there's a unique optimal
policy
we can we also need to show the value
functions are going to be optimistic
so this is done very easily in the
primal model optimistic framework
so here we know that our objective
function is equal to the value by strong
duality
and because our occupancy measures are
bounded and because our rewards are
bounded we know
that this is going to be bounded by h
minus h so we don't need to clip anymore
additionally it's going to be optimistic
because we know the true transition
function is
in the confidence set of the primal
problem with high probability
and lastly we can show that if we don't
want to use this confidence bound
perhaps it's a little bit messy to
calculate
if we have an upper bound on it then we
can also use this and we'll still get an
optimistic value
function and this is particularly useful
for example if
our distance is some normal distance
between
p and p hat and then we can upper bound
d star by the
dual norm
okay so with these results we can
provide a general framework
for optimism and episodic reinforcement
learning the first thing we do is we
define
a model optimistic confidence set such
that p is in the confidence set of high
probability
we then compute this conjugate d star
and then we can put that into the
value optimistic equations that we had
and compute the optimal policy via
backwards
recursion and this means that we can get
the best of both worlds
these algorithms will benefit from a
simple probabilistic analysis which can
be done in the model optimistic
framework
and also a computationally inefficient
implementation in the value optimistic
perspective
and we can also easily ban the regret of
these algorithms
so if this cb is a
confidence band defined in terms of the
conjugate distance
what we do is we can fix an episode t
and a stage
h and we can just use the expression
from value optimistic
algorithm to substitute here and we use
the bellman equations
to get another expression for v pi
then expanding this a little bit
we have a martingale and we also have
this term here so this
because p is going to be in the
confidence set with high probability in
the primal confidence set with high
probability
we can actually bound this by the
conjugate distance again
because if we go back to where it was
defined
there it's just the maximum over p which
is
a density function
and so we can recurse on h here
and so we see that the optimistic v1
minus the
true value of v1 is going to be bounded
by the sum of this martingale difference
sequence
plus the sum of the uncertainty terms
we then use optimism in the primal space
to use to show that our value
optimistic value function is indeed
optimistic so we cannot found the true
value func true optimal value function
by our optimistic value function
with this we can just sum up can i ask a
quick
yep
sorry finish finish here no no go ahead
go ahead i think i'd pretty much
yeah yeah i just wanted to ask in the in
the theorem when you define this cb
you're using p hat in there be hd
so are you going to use the cb hd in the
algorithm
and if so then do you have to always
compute it using p hat
yeah you always need to are you
maintaining the model as well
so these are all model based but then
isn't it like a model
or this is the model basic but i thought
you were going to give a way to
construct a model
like the value optimistic algorithm
using yeah so
we're considering value optimistic
algorithms where we use this empirical
density here
okay okay so you'll maintain a p
hat but the uh but you will not
maintain it a like a set of fee
yeah exactly so you don't have this
confidence anymore which is what's often
complicating the
implementation without optimizing over
that confidence that
all right
so once with this result here we can
add a fourth step if we like to our
framework where we just need to bound
the
sum of these confidence terms so this
is often it's okay it's not normally too
hard to do
and so we'll illustrate this with some
examples
so if we consider ucrl2 for example
here we just define our primal distance
using the l1 norm
and it's known that with this distance
metric
we can set epsilon so like the bound on
how far we can go
to these of order square root s over n
and this will contain the true
transition probability with
transition density with high probability
then our conjugate d star is going to be
epsilon so the square root s over n
times the span of v so when it comes to
summing up our confidence bounds
what we can just bound the span of v by
h because we're in the
episodic setting and then we can
sum over these which terms which are
basically going to be of order one over
square root n
for every state action pair that we
visit and so that will sum up
quite nicely to give us regret of order
square root t
and that's the same as the regret bound
that was shown in the original ucl
to paper and similarly we can
incorporate several other algorithms
that already exist into this framework
so we can use
bernstein confidence intervals for ucl2b
we can use the kl divergence to define
them or we can use a choice
chi-squared distance to define our
confidence intervals
however in the tabular setting all of
these approaches have sub-optimal
dependence on s
which we haven't been able to remove so
far
are there any questions so far so do you
think the
the dependence on s so this is so this
dependence extra dependence on s is
compared to
the bounds the
the purely value optimistic ones so like
ucbi
managed to get rid of so get rid of the
square
s but we haven't managed to find a valid
distance metric in the primal that
corresponds to ucbvi
okay so we can also extend this
to factored linear mdps here we make
an assumption that our transition matrix
can be factorized
by a feature matrix and some
unknown matrix m so this is going to be
the key quantity
determining the transitions whereas
these this vector
phi corresponds to known features
and this means that for every policy pi
there exists
a theta such that the q function can be
expressed used
as an inner product of the feature
vector and this theta
and again we can in the case where
there's no uncertainty so we don't have
to estimate the transition density
there is again duality results which
we've shown in our paper i think
perhaps existed before but we're not
sure and
yeah so these basically show that we can
again define occupancy measures
and we need to do a little bit of
projection here but
what we get is we get the in the value
optimistic
algorithms we can define a feta hat and
then use that to define
a value
so then the natural question is how we
incorporate uncertainty
and what we're going to do is we're
going to estimate this matrix m
and it can be shown that for any
vector v m minus m hat is a vector
valued martingale
so we can apply known concentration
results to this and get a confidence set
around
m the question is then how we use this
to build
algorithms that fit into our framework
so there are two ways that we can do it
in the first we construct local
confidence sets so this is similar to
what we were doing in the tabular
setting
we're defining confidence sets for each
xa pair
and then in the dual space we see that
the confidence bound added to the value
function
is the weighted inverse norm here
and the algorithm that this presents in
the value optimistic
framework is equivalent to lsvbi ucb
by uh chi jin and others i think
and this we get the same regret bound as
them however our model optimistic
perspective allows us to
um find a new analysis framework for it
alternatively we can use global
confidence sets where we directly
constrain these matrices
and this will again will give us some
confidence term
which we can show is almost equivalent
to the eleanor algorithm by zanette
at all and again we get the same regret
as them
and again benefiting from a new
probabilistic
perspective by using the model
optimistic framework
um just can i ask a
knife question yep uh
maybe you can go back to the previous
slide where there was the confidence set
so the number of parameters that is in m
is it's too large right but somehow
the number of parameters not going to
show up
um so you mean when we do these global
confidence sets here uh i mean like
global
yeah like look yeah like here like on
the previous slide
it seems that uh yeah i didn't have
time to sorry yeah i don't understand
what's going on here so your
bonding another difference between
eminent hat m has i don't know like
s times the parameters or something like
that and s is big
right you don't want s to show so
basically you are projecting it through
for some fixed vector yeah
and for any fixed vector this is what's
happening but this is an
s dimensional vector so then like how do
you use this
in the proof uh so it seems that the
confidence set is not really for
you know the difference between eminem
hat in some norm but
the projection of eminem hat
vector v which is an estimation of
vector high dimensional vector
so that is something that you have to do
with this
to be able to use this so how does the
story that you were presenting before
so we when we define
the confidence sets using m
using like some distance in terms of m
we
consider the supremum over all of some
feasible class of value functions
okay so we consider taking
covering uh yeah it's a covering
argument yeah
shouldn't that bring out ass basically
like in the like if you take a super all
past
release then like an s is going to
appear on the right hand side
square root s i think yeah an x
extra square because yeah yes i
yeah it's the same as the covering
argument that you use
yeah but like i think this doesn't
appear and so i'm
really wondering about what what what's
going on
yeah you only need to cover the set of
linear value functions
pretty much it's not all volume
functions
but are somewhat smooth so when you
you you need to redefine this duality in
terms of like what are the value
functions that may actually appear under
this linear model
and then once you do that then you're
down okay so there's a little tweak that
you need to add
to the internet favorite or like maybe
it was part of it but i just
no i don't think i explained that well
enough so thanks for clarifying
but do you think like just following up
on that like do you think that might
be the source of uh not
matching the dependence on s exactly
compared to value function based
approach
like earlier so earlier yeah in the
previous
in the previous previous year we think
that like so
here when we're using these global
confidence sets we think that
we're doing better and the reason is
because we're using global confidence
sets and so
an idea that we had about how to improve
the dependence on s
would be to try global confidence sets
in the tabular setting as well
so by the way by global you mean that
it's not stage wise or
uh like no it is still stage wise it
just doesn't depend on x
yeah the state-wise company not
state-wise exactly
so you have like three minutes or so
sorry i think this is basically the last
slide so
it's all good um yeah
so just to summarize what we've talked
about
so we've shown there's a relationship
between model optimistic and value
optimistic algorithms
and presented a framework for designing
analyzing and implementing such
algorithms and tabular setting
we've also been able to extend this to
factored linear mdps
however as we've been discussing there's
still a gap in the tabular settings so a
future direction for work would be to
try and close that gap which could be
defining
global confidence sets for tabular
setting or just to thinking a bit more
carefully about a distance function
there's also been some work on related
work and robustness so it would be nice
to combine those ideas together
for the average reward setting we think
most of the structural results will
carry over
and then it's just how we use this to be
able to get an
efficient algorithm and lastly we can
always consider
removing the linear assumption and
considering more general
function approximation so
here are some references thanks
thank you again yeah we have question
times one minute for like some questions
and uh i'll ask the next speaker to set
up
by then uh emily
yes should i try to share my screen
i see one question for kara could you
please repeat the last explanation
sorry i missed the part it asked you we
still need to maintain
hat b but not a whole set of p
yes so we need to
[Music]
if we consider model based value
optimistic algorithms they still use an
estimated
p hat to construct the for the backwards
recursion step
but we don't need to we don't need to
care about like
the confidence set around p hat we just
add the expiration bonus to the value
function
so related to that just very quickly uh
for this
uh linear factor the mdp is though i
think you just need to keep all the data
just and you don't need to have these
big big matrices around because you need
these inner products only
this matrices appear somewhere and then
you can simplify things so you get
exactly back lsvi ucb
yeah sometimes you can do this
simplification maybe
okay yeah i do feel like the worst case
we might be the
in the conjugate might be the issue of
issue with the tabular setting
dependence on s
like that's what we always felt whenever
we tried to improve the bound that this
because the p hat is very very
correlated with the value function
and yeah yeah yeah
we did look a little bit trying to sort
of
sorry i'll leave this till later i don't
want to eat into emily's time
right yeah i'm excited to invite our
next speaker